[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى بانوراما مجددا عود
سيف الاسلام القذافي الظهور مطالبا بفتح
باب الترشح للرئاسه سيف الاسلام دعا الى
السماحي للجميع الليبيين بالترشح الى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وعدم اقصاء المترشح
من اجل اعاده ليبيا الى سكه الانتخابات من
جديد وفقا بيان لفريقه السياسي هذا واتهم
البيان الاطراف السياسيه المتصدره للمشهد
السياسي باجهاض الانتخابات ومصادره اراده
ملايين الليبيين من خلال الابقاء على
الخلافات حول القاعده الدستوريه للبقاء في
السلطه كما اعتبر الفريق السياسي القذافي
ان النقاط الخلافيه بين الاطراف تضاف الى
ما تم الاتفاق عليه بين ممثلين البرلمان
ومجلس الدوله على استبعاد من صدرت بحقهم
احكام قضائيه حتى لو كانت غير نهائيه من
الترشح شارك ذلك الى ان اختزال مشكله
ليبيا في فقرتين بالقاعده الدستوريه هو
اختار بازمه وماساه ليبيا وسيؤدي الى
اجهاض الانتخابات مره اخرى اقترحا لتفادي
ذلك السماح لجميع المترشحين بالمشاركه في
الانتخابات معتبرا ان اقصاء اطراف بعينها
قد يقود الى الطعن في نتائجها وعدم
الاعتراف بها او مقاطعه
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من طرابلس احمد ابو
عرقوب المحلل السياسي ومن تونس عز الدين
عقيل الكاتب السياسي الليبي وابدا معك سيد
احمد حول هذا البيان وخروج سيف الاسلام
مجددا ما الذي يعنيه
وبالمقابل خرج بمبادرتين سابقتين كيف
تختلف هذه المبادره
نعم مساء الخير استاذه ميسون تحيه طيبه
ليك ولضيفك الكريم الاستاذ عز الدين عقيل
ولكافه المشاهدين الكرام اعتقد بان سيف
الاسلام القذافي كانت له مبادره في وقت
سابق عندما اعلن عن انه سوف ينسحب من
السباق للانتخابات الرئاسيه شريطه ان
ينسحب كل الاسماء الجدليه من السباق
الانتخابي واليوم او امس عاد الينا مذكرا
بفشل الانتخابات في 24 ديسمبر واشار الى
القوه القاهره التي منعت همم عمليه
الانتخابات في 24 ديسمبر الماضي القوه
القاهره كما هو معلوم وكما هو مذكور في
البيان بانها هي ترشح سيف الاسلام القذافي
في الانتخابات الماضيه كان سببا رئيسيا لي
تعطيل عمليه الانتخابات باعتبار ان هناك
قوه دوليه همم لا لا تحب ان ترى عوده
النظام السابق في ليبيا وقد يكون له تر
وفوز سيف الاسلامي القذافي في اي انتخابات
قد يعود به الى الله الحرب
والتوقيتها الان ما الذي يريده
بين مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله اااه او على
مستوى الرئاسه بين عقيله صالح وخالد
المشري محاولات لتمرير قاعده دستوريه
كخطوه اولى ثم ااه يعني تغيير السلطه
التنفيذيه هناك شروط قد يعني قدمت لعجيله
صالح هو خالد المشري همم يعني بهدف تغيير
السلطه التنفيذيه لا يعني لا يمكن الذهاب
في مسار السلطه التنفيذيه الا بعد حسم
القاعده الدستوريه يعني زخم كبير حول
اعداد قاعده دستوريه همم
ويعني هناك خطوات متقدمه همم في هذا في
هذا الملف وابرز النقاط التي تم التوافق
عنها هي اقصاء سيف الاسلام القذافي من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الماده 99
يعني نصف صريح وواضح خاص بسيف الاسلام جدا
ده فيه يقصيه
شخصيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
فاليوم خروج سيف الاسلام القذافي فريق
السياسي يحذر الاجسام السياسيه ويحذر مجلس
النواب والمجلس الدوله من عمليه الاقصاء
ويذكر بانه لا لان التيار الذي يتبع سيف
الاسلام سيف الاسلام القذافي كبير وربما
هذه العمليه قد تؤدي الى عرقله اجراء
الانتخابات
وما الفائده منها الان
تحياتي لك السيده ميسون ولاخي احمد
والاستاذه جمهورك الكريم في البدايه يا
اختي ميسون يهمني جدا نوضح نقطتين النقطه
الاولى هو انني لست هنا ممثل لسيف القذافي
ولست محامي الدفاع عنه واما المساله
الثانيه التي
الترتيب هو انني ساتحدث في السياق الذي
يهم سيف القذافي وذلك لثلاثه اسباب رئيسيه
اولا لاسباب حقوقيه سياسيه وتانيا لرفض
املاءات اجنبيه تحاول ان توجه الانتخابات
الليبيه وثالثه لان المصالحه السياسيه هي
الاصل والاساس وما لم ينجز بعد المصالحه
السياسيه فان اي بعد اخر لن ينجح ابدا من
ابعاد المصالح الوطنيه
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه بعد ان خرجت من
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهي قويه ومنتصره
لجات شعوبها الى انتخاب قاده عسكريين
انتقموا تشرشل وانتخب شارلي جول حتى الدول
التي كانت ترزح تحت الدكتاتوريه العسكريه
وهي اسبانيا واليونان والبرتغال لم يطالب
رغم المد الحر الكبير الذي حصل بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لم يطالب بمواجهه
انظمتهم لان الانظمه العسكريه في ذلك
الوقت كانت هي الانظمه المناسبه في ظلها
هشاشه الاوضاع عالم هشاشه هشاشه الامل
استقواق بهذا الاطار انا قادم انا اعرف ما
اقول
انا على الشاشه
وبالتالي انا شخصيا اذا ما قدر لي ان
اشارك في الانتخابات فانني ساصوت لاي مرشح
من خلفيه عسكريه يعني لو وجدت قدام يحفتر
لو وجد جدا يا حسين عبد الله لو جد جدا
محمد الشيخ او محمد عجاج وهو من خلفيه
شراطيه فانني ساذهب راسا لان ليبيا اوضعها
اليوم هي اسوا 1,000 مره من اوضاع الدول
الاوروبيه المنتصره او الدول الغربيه
المنتشره يعني
في القذافي يعني اي اي حديث الان يكون في
صالح سيف ليس معناه انني مع سيف او في
صفيف ننتقل الان الى الى ما تفضلت به شوفي
استاذه ميسون الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والانجليز وجه انذار واوامر شديده وواضحه
لكل من عقيله صالح والمشري انكما لن تنجح
ابدا ولن يسمح لكما ابدا بانتاج قاعده
دستوريه الا في اطار قانون عزل سياسي يقسي
السيف القدافي يعني سيف القذافي نقصي مقصي
لا اظنه ابدا سوف يكون مشاركا في
الانتخابات خاصه واننا سمعنا السفير
الامريكي وهو يقول كل صفاقه بان سيف ظهر
عليهم كظهور قنبله في غرفه مغلقه ويقول ان
سيف هو الذي افسدنا الانتخابات بسبب
بوجودك وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان سيف اصلا
سيكون موجود ولكن واضح جدا انه لديه
معلومات على ان يتم اشياء تدور في
الكواليس على ان الانتخابات ربما ستتزحزح
من مكان هذه السبب او اخر مع انني لا اظن
ابدا لان كما تسبب اخر لخوف الولايات
المتحده والانجليز من الانتخابات وهي ان
القوائم التي سلمها عماد السايح للسفاره
الانجليزيه والامريكيه حول المرشحين لمجلس
النواب وجدوا لاول مره ان التكنوقراط
لبلاد وكبار خبراءها مرشحون في هذه
الانتخابات وان حدودهم عاليه جدا في
دوائرهم يعني ان الولايات المتحده
والانجليز سوف يجيدون انفسهم امام برلمان
في غايه الخطوره
التي ذكرتها ولكن اطول مني
لا بس
سيد احمد تفضل
تدخلات الخارجيه وايضا عدم عزم القذافي
سيف الاسلام الى المشاركه في الانتخابات
القادمه اييه لماذا خرج اذا بمثل هذا
البيان واذا كانت الطرحات الموجوده هي
الاشارات التي ذكرها ضيفي قبل قليل هل لها
ان تؤثر
وتربك المشهد الان السياسي ام ماذا
صحيح استاذه ميسون بالنسبه للتدخلات
الخارجيه انا انا لدي معلومات مؤكده من
مده ماضيه وذكرت هذا عبر شاشتكم وواقره في
نشرات سابقه بان قد وصلت تهديدات فعليه من
الجانب الامريكي والجانب الانجليزي الى
المستشار عقيله صالح والسيد خالد المشري
بضروره انجاز قاعده دستوريه واعاده الزخم
للانتخابات وان هذه الفرصه الاخيره امام
مجلس النواب مجلس الدوله لانجاز قاعده
دستوريه وقانون انتخابات ووضع جدول زمني
للذهاب للانتخابات ومن ثم بعد كل هذا يمكن
الحديث عن تغيير السلطه التنفيذيه التي
سوف تشرف على الانتخابات وفي حال فشلوا
هذه في الفرصه الاخيره فان مجلس همم مجلس
الرئاسي مسحوق مدعوما به يعني همم مدعوما
به همم الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا بمواقف
هذان الدولتان سوف يصدر مرسوم رئاسي
بقاعده دستوريه وقانون الانتخابات وت
للمفوضيه الوطنيه العليا للانتخابات
لاعاده فتح سجل الناخبين واعاده فتح باب
الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
اليوم سيف الاسلام القذافي يقول انا اريد
ان اشارك في هذه الانتخابات ويذاك تلتفت
لصوت الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا هناك دول
اخرى تستطيع افشاء العمليه الانتخابات
هناك مؤيدين لي في الداخل الليبي سوف لن
يشاركوا في العمليه الانتخابيه
العامه
من من هو رجل المرحله اذا ما صحه العسكر
ااا حل ربما لليبيا في هذه الفتره
انا احترم راي الاستاذ عز الدين عقيل
كثيرا وهو يعني استاذنا ولكن لديه وجهه
نظر اخرى حول من ان يكون له الاحقيه في
قياده المرحله الحاليه في ليبيا من يستطيع
قياده المرحله الحاليه في ليبيا هو من
يستطيع التجول في كل ليبيا لا يمكنني ان
ارشح شخص معزول في منطقه عسكريه في منطقه
معينه او شخص تائه في الصحراء وامنحه صوتي
او او شخص لا يستطيع الذهاب الى منطقه
الشرقيه او شخص موجود في المنطقه الشرقيه
عرض اللي طرحه السيد
يتعلق بعوده سيف الاسلام من عدمه او فيما
يتعلق بالشخص المناسب الان تعليقه السيد
عز الدين
اريد ان اوضح نقطه جدا غايه في الاهميه
على سيف الاسلام قدافي ان يفهم انه في
ليبيا مشكله وليس حل انت اسمح لي اسمحلي
انا شخصيا اذا ما قدر لي ان ان ان اشارك
في الانتخابات
من خلفيه عسكريه يعني هذا قرار الخاص
ااا كاتب سياسي وقارئ قارئ للمشهد
وبالتالي
لمصلحه البلد اليس كذلك
هكذا ارتيد
كل الولايات المتحده جابت ايزون هاوس بعد
الحرب العالميه جينيرال يعني الشعب الليبي
وضع افضل من الولايات المتحده الانجليز
جابوا تشرش الورد ده ثاني في ال 55
الفرنسيس جابوا شارل ديجون اليونانين
والاسبان والبرتغال ارتضوا ان يضلوا
يرزحون تحت
نقطه
جدا مهمه السيد احمد ذكرها انه الشخص
الوحيد القادر الان على ان يحكم ليبيا هو
من هو قادر على التحرك في كل مناطقها ومش
محصور بمنطقه معينه في رجل بهذه الصفات
شوفي شوفي يا استاذه ميسون شوفي يا استاذه
ميسون اذا كنا احنا بنجروا الانتخابات
بحسب قول السيد احمد ومازال الرئيس المرشح
حتى بعد ما ينجح في الانتخابات غير قادر
ان يذهب الى منطقه دون اخرى اي انتخابات
هذه هذه هذه المهزله هذا النتيجه ليتحدث
عنها احمد اذا حصلت فهذه المهزله رئيس
منتخب من الشعب في انتخابات يشرف عليها
المجتمع الدولي ثم ياتي احمد ويقول بان
هذا الرئيس ربما لا يستطيع ان يذهب الى
المكان الفلاني اذا لماذا هناك انتخابات
اصلا
لان هذا الرجل لن تكن له سياده الدوله
ماذا يعني هذا الرجل لن يكون محمي من هذا
المجتمع الدولي الذي يفرض على الانتخابات
وكان معنا ايضا من طرابلس احمد ابو عرقوب
المحلل السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك بانوراما
انتهت شكرا متابعه مشاهدينا اقوموا معنا